alors est ce vrai cette grande nouvelle
que nous allons déplacer la tour eiffel
oui nous allons faire de dimanche
tranchait environ d'une quinzaine de
mètres de profondeur ensuite nous allons
mettre de très grosses grosses rails et
ensuite nous allons mettre les pieds
englober de ciment de béton armé ensuite
nous mettons donc aux quelles raisons
techniques pour déplacer la tour eiffel
ah bon mais parce que c'est très
difficile j'imagine de la traînée qu'on
fait bien sûr on ne peut pas déplacer
une tour eiffel de ce poids là comme ça
on nous sommes forcés de prendre m de
croo trahi par exemple à l'école
militaire nous allons mettre des treuils
très puissant et nous allons la tirer
progressivement à mettre à leur bête en
grand maximum et ensuite
nous allons la mettre environ à 100 150
mètres de l'école militaire et
pouvez-vous nous dire pour quelles
raisons va-t-on déplacer la tour eiffel
haye compte faire un stade municipal
d'environ cent mille personnes juste un
autre emplacement si je comprends bien
mais pourquoi n'at-on pas annoncé cette
nouvelle bien avant moi c'est un peu
secret quoi assez délicat gym à jouer il
ne savait pas exactement ce qu'ils
voulaient faire si vous voulez la
démonter ou pour la reconstruire là bas
ou alors là la tirer alors maintenant le
prenons procédé américain nous allons là
de déplacement comme on déplace en
amérique exactement légumes a d'ailleurs
fait en france on déplace une maison à
l'emplacement vue et les travaux vont
durer combien de temps faut compter deux
ans deux ans de travaux et comme les
personnes vont participer à l'opération
aura une feuille tout sera en place
saura compter environ 3 400 personnes
alors ici voyez vous avez la tour eiffel
qui fait à l'heure actuelle 300 m
ça paraît pas mais c'est quand même du
joli travail mais dans deux ans si on
venait à paris vous enverra plus on a
repéré plus non plus à cet emplacement
ce qu'elle sait quand elle sera en face
l'école militaire ont ré percevait là
bas tout en tout temps font là-bas
ah oui alors on va déprécier la tour
eiffel
ah non non non la démonte absolument pas
ce sera montée sur chariot et vérin est
tirée par des hommes non non ça gênera
pas illégal le militaire passera en
dessous les quatre oui oui c'est passé
c'est alors un pied à la pied par pied
on va la montée sont là
que pensez vous du fait qu'on va
déplacer la tour eiffel est embêtant
pour moi
dix ans que je suis ici alors comment je
vais faire je vais vendre quoi elle vous
savez qu'on va la placer juste en face
de l'école militaire
avant je pourrais pas y aller devant
l'école militaire pour quelle raison ça
regarde la place de paris y'a pardon
quoi ça regarde la place de paris le
commandant de la place de paris ces
militaires devant l'école et vous pouvez
voir rentrer de marrons l'apurement bois
ou ici ça fait partie de la préfecture
de police mais l'avant ça fait partie de
l'armée et alors qu'en pensez-vous en
déficit qu'allez vous faire vous bah je
sais pas j'ai pas
je pense qu'on va offrir de francs
j'avais vente de marrons frères hamia se
dérouler merci